people are dying at the rate of 300 a
day
and so i can certainly understand the
high level of anxiety that would exist
in italy and in many countries across
europe
as is regularly conveyed to me and so
they have some real
difficulties there they are in a an
unbridled
crisis situation that is not the
situation in australia
but nevertheless we've been able to
secure our supplies
let's speak to ben lange now he's an mep
for germany's social democrats and
chairs the european parliament's
committee
on foreign trade mr lange thanks for
speaking to dw today
tell me does italy have the eu's support
on this decision
the support by the european commission
but not in general the support because
i think the instrument expert control
and expert ban is not the right
instrument
to solve the problem with a single
company and of course
as you mentioned in your report there is
a problem with astrazeneca because
they are not sticking to the obligation
of the contract
you've already voiced an opinion on the
export ban in a recent tweet you called
the move
a mistake and said a quote pandora's box
was opened
so are you concerned that the european
union could be triggering
a protectionist vaccine war here
indeed that's a big risk so as i
mentioned we have
a problem with one company but we use an
instrument
which has triggered all companies and
the whole world
and of course we have reaction for
example from
several countries in latin america
asking what's going on in europe
on the one hand you are asking in the
ewto to reduce
tariffs and cut down non-tariff barriers
and at the same moment you establish a
protective
mirrors inside the european union this
is not
this is not fitting together and they
are right
i think this is the excuse
of course for other countries to
establish similar protective measures
with vaccine rollouts in the eu having
been comparatively slow
doesn't it make sense though for
governments to prevent vaccines leaving
eu territory
no we are living in an open world and of
course we have also some supply of
vaccine
coming from outside the european union
and you can easily
argue why should they supply for that
chain which is used inside the european
union
no it's a global problem and we need a
global solution
and vaccine against corona should be a
public good
and it's totally not acceptable if we
have a contract with a single company
and they are not fulfilling the
obligation
regardless where the company is based
and regarded
to which nation this machine
should go we have to stick to the
principle
if there's a contract concluded then of
course
both partners have to stick to the
obligation
what would you suggest governments do
though to overcome these vaccine
shortages
we need more production capacity that's
true
and perhaps this was also a fought in
the
vagine strategy of the european union we
invest in the research
in the preparation of the production but
we didn't invest
in the production capacity and of course
it's not so easy to produce this modern
kind of vaccine
and we need more capacity and
now the european commission established
the task force under the industrial
economic
commissioner mr return to establish
exactly
this procedure to go for
more production capacity and i think we
should really go
for a little bit more pressure to the
companies to allow
other companies partner companies to use
the patents
and the technical know-how to establish
more
production capacity all right ben lange
of the european parliament's
international trade committee thank you
very much for your time